So, let's look at an example of fabrication costs.
Suppose that the cost of manufacturing a wafer is $5,000. So,
we pay $5,000 to manufacture a whole wafer and cut it up into chips.
Let's consider what happens when you have some really small chips so
that we can fit 400 of them on a wafer. And then we want to manufacture large
chips that are four times the size of the small chips. So, now you would think.
That we would have 100 of those on our wafer. But because the wafer is round and
the chips are square, we lose some chips along the edge.
So let's say that we can fit only 96 of these large chips on our wafer.
And finally we will consider huge chips that are four times again. So
they're four times. The size of the large chip and
then 24 of them would be a quarter of this. But because, again,
the wafer is round and the chip is square we lose some more along the edges. So
let's say only 20 of them can fit on a wafer. And
let us also suppose that there are 10 defects on each wafer.
What we want to compute is what's the manufacturing cost of a small large and
huge chip. The chip cost will be the $5,000 for
a wafer divided by how many good chips we get per wafer.
So now for our small chips, what we get. Is that the cost is equal to
$5,000 divided by, we have 400 chips on a wafer.
But we lose 10 to defects, so we really have $5,000 for 390 chips.
And that gives us a cost of $12.80 to manufacture a working chip.
For a large chip, we get the cost to be $5,000 divided
by 96 of them fit on a chip. But again, these defects are going to be on
the wafer, and they will affect 10 of our chips, so we lose 10 to the defects.
So we end up we paying $5,000 for manufacturing and
get only 86 working chips. So we get $58.20 as the cost of our chips,
so note that our chip is only four times the size of a small chip.
But the cost is about five times the cost of a smaller chip. And finally for
our huge chip. The cost is going to be $5,000,
we get only 20 chips fabricated. And now there are ten defects on a wafer.
But with chips this big, it seems likely that maybe two of these defects
are going to end up on the same chip. So instead of losing ten chips to defects,
because each defect effects a whole chip. Let's say that we only lose
nine chips because of this defense. So we put in $5,000 and manufacture only
11 chips that work. This is much more than four times the cost of a large chip.
This means really that if you're fabricating chips that are really large,.
Any slight increase or decrease in chip size is going to significantly change
the cost. We have seen that here the difference was five times instead of four.
Here the difference is almost ten times instead of four. So
if this is what manufacturing cost look like and if we combine this
with what Moore's law gives us. Which is we can fit more stuff on the same chip.
We really have two choices when we get a generation of Moore's Law to play for
us. One, we can have a smaller chip that does exactly the same things that
a larger chip could do previously because now we can make things smaller. And,
as you can see, getting things smaller gives us much lower cost.
So one way of benefiting from Moore's Law, is to getting smaller, and
thus a lot cheaper than before while keeping the same functionality.
The other way of benefiting from Moore's Law, is to build something new that has
the same area as old thing. And that means that we get something faster, and
more capable for the same cost that the old thing had. So,
if we are interested in high performance processors, typically we will do this.
But if we are interested in doing something that could not be done before,
then this is what we usually benefit from. Take a cell phone for example.
Early on, what we wanted to put in a cellphone, could not be very smart,
so we had, non-smartphones. Eventually, the processor that would be
required to make a smartphone, became small enough. To put in a cell phone and
also cheap enough so that we can afford it, and that's when we
started having cell phones. Similar things occurred with digital watches, and
all sort of things where eventually what we want will fit
in where we want it. It's just a matter of how long do we need to wait for it,
because of this, because. Whatever functionality we need,
will eventually be cheap enough and small enough to fit.